tout de suite après la caisse nombreux
sont les clients qui livre facilement
les emballages plastiques et cartons
la deuxième opération du collectif
citoyen plastique attaque il ya des
recherches ont été mises en place et qui
démontre ce plastique s'il était
biodégradable on n'aurait pas eu
effectivement à ça donc 30 consent n'est
pas dégradable donc ça reste à plusieurs
des valeurs comme ça pollue la planète
réduire le plastique une prise de
conscience mondiale selon les ong
greenpeace notamment chaque année plus
de 12 millions de tonnes de plastique
finissent dans les océans les emballages
de trop dont le mari et moi le tri
sélectif mais bon c'est vrai que dans ce
sens on pas de plus pour la protection
de la planète
à la maison je vais très attention tri
sélectif tout ça je fais très attention
je comprends vos voix entre les jambes
ont sous la mer y revient déjà un fils
tim que la plongée sous-marine jeudi qu'
on peut même plus pêcher mais tant
qu'ils voulaient tordu boudou les
alternatives existent il s'agit donc de
sensibiliser les consommateurs mais
aussi les dirigeants des grandes
surfaces
ici néanmoins ils n'ont pas souhaité
répondre à nos questions
la loi c'est la loi donc tout client
peut déposer son plastique même à la
caisse et dire non je n'en veux pas donc
nous sommes allés vers l'est
les dirigeants et demander effectivement
certaines possibilités que nous
puissions travailler ensemble de manière
pacifique pourquoi justement les choses
évoluent ici en martinique comme ça
évolue ailleurs la dominic la métropole
pas ça évolue beaucoup dans le monde et
ici on est encore à la traîne
d'ici 2020 le plastique à usage unique
sera interdite vers gobelets assiettes
jetables paille entre autres le
plastique interdit également dans les
cantines et les crèches dès janvier 2025